>>> RISK OF ILLNESS KEY CONCERNS
IN SOOUT SUDAN AFTER SEVERE
FLOODING HIT THE COUNTRY, THE
WORST IN NEARLY SIX DECADES.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS IS
AFFECTING MORE THAN 700,000
PEOPLE AND ISOLATING PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY.
CNN'S CLARISSA WARD IS IN SOUTH
SUDAN, REPORTING ON THE TOLL
IT'S TAKEN ON RESIDENTS.
>> Reporter: JUST FOUR MONTHS
AGO, THIS WAS A BUSTLING TOWN OF
11,000 PEOPLE.
THEN THE FLOODS CAME, BIBLICAL
IN SCALE, LEAVING IT SUBMERGED
UNDER WATER AND LARGELY CUT OFF.
AS WE ARRIVE IN DING DING THERE
ARE FEW SIGNS OF LIFE.
JUST SOME BELONGINGS STASHED IN
THE TREETOPS.
THE ONLY PROTECTION FROM THE
WATERS THAT HAVE INUNDATED MUCH
OF SOUTH SUDAN.
SO THIS ENTIRE TOWN HAS BEEN
FLOODED SINCE AUGUST, AND THE
WATERS ARE STILL GETTING HIGHER
AND HIGHER, EVEN THOUGH THE
RAINY SEASON IS NOW OVER.
HI!
A GROUP OF WOMEN CATCH SIGHT OF
US AND WANT TO TALK.
HI.
WHERE ARE YOUR HOMES?
HAVE YOUR HOMES BEEN DESTROYED?
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> Reporter: THEY SURVIVED YEAR
OF VICIOUS CIVIL WAR HERE.
THESE FLOODS MAY POSE THE
GREATEST THREAT YET.
THEY TELL US THEIR CROPS HAVE
BEEN COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
SO WHAT ARE YOU LIVING ON RIGHT
NOW?
WHAT ARE YOU SURVIVING ON?
THE LILYS?
THE WATER LILYS.
ARE PEOPLE GETTING SICK FROM THE
DIRTY WATER?
MANY PEOPLE HAVE WATER BORN
DISEASES, SHE EXPLAINS.
THE WELLS WERE ALL COVERED SO WE
HAVE TO DRINK THIS WATER.
WHILE SOUTH SUDAN IS NO STRANGER
THE SEASONAL FLOODING YOUNTY
STATE HASN'T BEEN HIT LIKE THIS
SINCE THE EARLY 1960s.
SCIENTISTS SAY THE FLOODS HAVE
BECOME MUCH MORE INTENSE AND
UNPREDICTABLE IN RECENT YEARS IN
PART BECAUSE OF GLOBAL WARMING.
JAMES.
HI, JAMES.
JAMES IS ONE OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED.
HE AGREES TO SHOW US WHAT'S LEFT
OF HIS FAMILY HOME.
OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S YOUR MOTORCYCLE.
NOTHING IS LEFT EXCEPT FOR HIS
CHILDREN'S DRAWINGS ON THE
WALLS.
SINCE THE CONFLICT ERUPTED WE'VE
NEVER HAD A REST, HE TELLS US.
OUR CHILDREN HAVE HAD NO RELIEF
FROM THE DANGERS.
NOW HE IS FORCED TO FLEE ONCE
AGAIN.
JOURNEY TO THE PROMISE OF DRY
LAND IS LONG AND ARDUOUS.
THE LUCKY ONES TRAVEL BY BOAT.
MOST SWIM OR WADE, MOVING SLOWLY
BUT PURPOSELY THROUGH THE MUDDY
WATERS.
SOME PUSH MAKESHIFT FLOATS PILED
HIGH WITH FAMILY MEMBERS AND
POSSESSIONS.
WE'VE COME ACROSS A GROUP OF
WOMEN WHOSE RAFT IS STUCK IN THE
MUD.
THE MEN OF THE FAMILY HAVE GONE
TO TRY SAVE THEIR LIVESTOCK.
SHE TELLS US THEY LEFT THEIR
DESTROYED HOME FOUR DAYS AGO.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN PUSHING THIS
RAFT FOR FOUR DAYS?
!
>> Reporter: YES, THEY TELL US.
ALONG THE WAY, THEY SAY THEIR
FOOD RAN OUT.
HOW OLD IS YOUR BABY?
>> FIVE TO SIX MONTHS.
>> Reporter: FIVE TO SIX MONTHS?
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT YOUR
CHILDREN?
YES, I'M WORRIED, SHE SAYS, AND
THAT'S WHY WE KEEP MOVING.
THEY STILL HAVE SEVERAL MILES TO
PUSH BEFORE THEY REACH THIS
NARROW STRIP OF DRY LAND.
ACCORDING TO UNICEF, SOME 6,000
PEOPLE HAVE NOW SETTLED HERE,
COMPLETELY DEPENDENT ON AID TO
SURVIVE.
>> THEY DON'T HAVE LATRINE, THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH FOOD FOR THEM
TO EAT.
>> Reporter: THEY DON'T HAVE
BATHROOM, THEY DON'T HAVE FOOD.
>> NOTHING.
>> Reporter: AND MORE PEOPLE
ARRIVING EVERY DAY?
>> PEOPLE CONTINUING DISPLACED
AND CONTINUE COMING.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
DOING EVERYTHING YOU CAN, BUT IS
IT ENOUGH?
>> THIS IS NOT ENOUGH, AND THERE
IS REASON WHY WE ARE CALLING FOR
DONOR COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN GET SCHOOLS, HEALTH
CARE, SERVICES.
WE PREVENT THEM TO DIE.
>> Reporter: AS STAGNANT WATERS
CONTINUE TO RISE, SO DO DISEASES
LIKE DIARRHEA AND HEPATITIS.
MALNUTRITION IN CHILDREN AT ITS
HIGHEST LEVEL SINCE 2013.
THOSE WHO MAKE IT ALL THE WAY TO
THE STATE CAPITAL FIND LITTLE
SANCTUARY.
SOME OF THE MAIN ROADS HAVE BEEN
TURNED INTO WATERWAYS.
CARS REPLACED BY CANOES.
JUST A MILE FURTHER, THE GHOSTLY
REMAINS OF WHAT WAS ONCE A
COMMERCIAL HUB.
THIS USED TO BE THE CENTRAL
SHOPPING AREA IN TOWN.
AS YOU CAN SEE, COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
ACCORDING TO AUTHORITIES, 90% OF
UNITY STATE HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
THESE FLOODS.
HERE THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AREN'T A HYPOTHETICAL
PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE, BUT
RATHER A REAL DISASTER IN THE
PRESENT.
>> WE ARE FIGHTING TO BLOCK THIS
WATER.
>> Reporter: THIS MINISTER
CONCEDES LOCAL AUTHORITIES WERE
COMPLETELY UNPREPARED AND ARE
NOW UNABLE TO COPE WITH THE
SCALE OF THE CRISIS.
>> WE DON'T HAVE ANY SUFFICIENT
FOR SURVIVAL.
>> Reporter: HOW MUCH LONGER CAN
YOU COPE WITH THE SITUATION AS
IT STANDS?
>> REALISTICALLY I CAN TELL YOU
WE DON'T KNOW, BUT WE ARE JUST
WORRIED ABOUT THE NEXT RAIN,
BECAUSE WE ARE TOLD THE WATER
BEHIND ME WILL NOT GO NOW. RECE.
>> Reporter: THEY DON'T HAVE
LONG.
THE NEXT RAINS ARE EXPECTED IN
MAY, AND IF THE CURRENT WATERS
DON'T RECEDE, THE FEAR IS THAT
THIS AREA WILL BE WIPED OFF THE
MAP.
DIKES ARE BEING BUILT TO TRY TO
HOLD BACK THE ENCROACHING
WATERS.
THE HANDFUL OF DIGGERS ARE NO
MATCH FOR THE VAST FLOODING.
BREACHES ARE COMMON, LEAVING
MANY WITH NO CHOICE BUT TO TAKE
MATTERS INTO THEIR OWN HAND,
HAST